bologna and northern Italy a city of
arched walkways called porticos they
stretch over 38 kilometers through the
old town in the middle of the historic
city center you'll find the zamboni
snack bar every day Sylvia a chair B and
her co-workers make fresh panzerotti is
here
panzerotti zar a specialty from poo Lea
and southern Italy made from pizza dough
they're filled with ingredients shaped
into small turnovers and dropped in the
deep fryer consider thesis and also
panzerotti are small but you know
they're amazing packed with so much
flavor tomato mozzarella and a variety
of natural ingredients it's impossible
not to enjoy them impossible a Canon
piacciono
Sylvia a chair be is studying bio
engineering but she'd rather spend her
time here behind the counter than in a
lecture hall she can even imagine
opening her own snack bar someday my god
II don't know well maybe some day since
I've learned so much here over the years
why not I'm a real pencil tgirl algoron
Cole crudo papa con chi sono
the shop sees lots of tourists as well
as locals one regular is businessman
Fiore munzo it were they may utiful I
come here because it's one of the best
places in Bologna for a classic
panzerotti when I was a strong i kept
eres feo it's kind of funny but where
I'm from Emporia panzerotti zar less
expensive than they are here that's
because we eat so many of them I'm am I
woke up it's one of our favorite dishes
lanzarote is here costs two euros fifty
apiece no matter whether they're filled
with spinach assorted veggies or ham and
joy that's an buon appetito